meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einem weiteren ipad spiel
was wir heute spielen werden immer
wahrscheinlicher
was sucht die face kämen da oben eine
andere beleuchtung ist gerade akku alle
und erlebt kommt auf deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht damit die beleuchtung nicht
ganz so scheiße ist kommt die face com
jetzt einfach nach da wir spielen heute
das spiel bauen
ich habe es noch nie gespielt das muss
ich wirklich sagen und ich bin mir
überhaupt nicht sicher wie es
funktioniert aber ich denke ich habe die
steuerung schon herausgefunden ich muss
einfach hier so hoch hüpfen und
eigentlich dachte core 2 bis 2 okay ich
schaffe es natürlich besser kann's sein
ist es nicht dachte schon das wäre immer
die gleichen levels was ist denn jetzt
wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwie
runterfallen
sport1 herr keinen sinn kommt die ganze
zeit gegen und von oben prasselt die
ganze irgendwas runter was ist denn das
hell wie crazy ist es her da kommt
einfach so richtig viele welchen was war
was was was ist das was kommt hier
runter was was sollen diese ganzen bälle
hey ich verstehe gar nichts mehr
ich muss doch her dass berger was soll
das ich komme hätten die bw oder ich
dachte es wären solche special teile die
mir irgendwie irgendwann irgendwas
anderes geben und ihnen die rocker
dieses spiel auch voll fällt mir grad
auf bosnisch wir schauen uns das mal
anders restaurant das er so wie tetris
für dumme bieri starten natürlich den
ganzen laden und jetzt werde ich meinen
high score von 2d fini
ich verstehe es einfach nicht es ruckelt
bei mir wie ich habe ein bisschen
gerückt das hat man nicht gehört so luca
jetzt gehen nicht auf diese blöden teile
ach jetzt weiß ich wie die punkte
gezählt werden immer wenn ich durch
dieses grüne dadurch gehe dann werden
ich muss einfach nur noch ein da ist es
jetzt und jetzt hier und hier nein nein
nein ich kann ich leben
so und jetzt kann ich um mein gott
freunde was ist nur los mit mir ich hab
schon highscore vier hier jetzt gehe ich
hier vor und so laut sein
es kommt nicht wieder meine nachbarin
rüber herr luca wenn du schreien
möchtest dann tut das in der zeit wo
wenig schlafen und zack highscore 3 und
jetzt hier durch hier lang und 4 haben
wir schon und jetzt kommt wieder diese
blöden flummis golf im klaren wie
hochkommen ich mache so und jetzt dieses
spiel ist so am ruckeln das tut mir echt
leid das hätte ich nicht gedacht jetzt
halt wirklich vorher bevor ich
aufgenommen habe noch nicht gespielt
diese man muss sich daran gewöhnen dass
ich die fans kam jetzt nicht hier habe
sondern hier
es ist besser einen krenkingen freunde
kennt sich irgendwer von euch eigentlich
mit mischpulten aus also ich hab die
einstellungen zwar immer so hingekriegt
dass das alles so ganz
also ich hab die einstellung zwar immer
so hingekriegt dass ich das ganze
bisschen passabel anhört aber zurzeit
ist es halt so dass bei mir mehr im mega
viele nebengeräusche sind die
beispielsweise einfach
wieso ruckelt das einfach mal
zwischendurch zu zehn jahre lang da sind
einfach so nebengeräusche wie teilweise
das nachbar die ganze zeit bord oder so
etwas renoviert wird und so eine scheiße
deswegen bräuchte ich da irgendwie
solche infos dass man quasi wirklich nur
die stimme wahrgenommen wird dass ich
was ich halt quasi sprecher und nicht
diese sachen wie vom bohren oder so auch
mit der kapitäns doch gleich tetris 2.0
einfach mein gott sie wegen dem
mischpult oder so felser irgendwer infos
hat welchen knopf ich da drehen muss
oder irgendwas machen muss dann wäre ich
da sehr sehr verbunden also ich hab halt
viele nebengeräusche und ich könnte
natürlich irgendwie den pegel einfach
unterstellen aber das ist halt meine
stimme auch leiser dementsprechend auch
ich mann ich weiß halt nicht so genau
nicht auf die landesteile die wollen wir
nur böses tun nicht darauf genug kann
nicht darauf gehen ja wir haben heißt
kurz weil das ist schon mal sehr schön
da kommen wieder komische belchen und
ich hüpfe letzter zeit hinter mir und
jetzt hier hoch hier nein und ich habe
das gefühl dass hier wird ein neuer high
score da bin ich mir sehr sicher
louis sieht es alles schneller online
soll jetzt lass mir nicht im stich
kleines wäldchen 3 nehmen wir hier die
feder mitnehmen wir hier noch eine feder
mit nehmen wir diese feder natürlich
auch noch mit und dann haben wir schon
hier und jetzt haben wir auch schon
alter meiner tonspur ist das gerade
richtig ausgerastet als ich das tor
gemacht habe
das sieht ja richtig ekelhaft außer man
tut mir leid mit der tonqualität die
wird irgendwann hoffentlich mal besser
ich versuche jetzt hier erstmal aber
dieses level hier so ein bisschen dass
ich hier ich muss doch irgendwie rein
kommt man einfach hochgeschleudert gar
keinen ding für king
sehen wir hier natürlich wieder diese
spirale mit dann nehmen wir jetzt auch
hier proben wieder die spirale mit oder
nämlich hier die spirale mit und wir
nehmen hier die spirale mit
und jetzt wo mein gott ich sehe das halt
nie dieses ding wegen der scheichs
werbung
conny ist einfach den flugmodus anmachen
hat wo finde ich dann hast du keine
werbung ja freunde aber ich nehme mit
einer app auf die internet ich hätte
jetzt über einen trick hierhin und der
ordens gilt nein ich nehme mit einer
apple lötzsch nicht nein nicht 10 10 mit
einer app auf die benötigt nun mal wlan
und wenig wlan habe kann ich kein flug
modus gleichzeitig an machen ich weiß
nicht wie du dich nicht als ob diese als
ob mir einfach alles was irgendwie böse
aussieht direkt auch böse ist nur weil
die böse sind diese teile mag ich auf
jeden fall schon mal viel lieber als
diese die alles schneller machen
online ist es wieder schnell auf fucking
fucks hier und jetzt
ich darf nicht so locker man freunde es
ist nicht wahr ich muss doch irgendwie
diesen katinka kreisky hier hinkriegen
so ist das mich erstmal durch bitte eben
eben schnell sagt danke jetzt hier wenn
ich den hunger der bürger uhrzeiger und
ich habe wieder keine ahnung wo ich
darum hüpfe ich will einfach mal mein
highscore von sechs knacken und danach
schwöre ich euch das dann auch das video
vorbei ist dann seid ihr endlich erlöst
aber ich kann es einfach nicht weil
diese blöden man jetzt kommt wieder die
freunde ich habe da keinen nerv
natürlich kannten doch ich will diesen
blöden heißt schaffen aber das geht
irgendwie
es ist doch nicht zu spielen
du musst hier irgendwo hüpfen das ist
leichter als ein bild wenn du denkst das
ist wirklich ihr das ist nicht schwer
ich muss es doch irgendwie hinkriegen
diese ich mache mit der nase hierbei ist
es mit der nase an freunde
ich glaube das kann ich nicht sein das
ist so kacke wie soll ich denn jetzt
auch letzterer lässt er jetzt kommen
a ich hab was dass ich die alle um
welchen kann oder wie jetzt
euro das ist okay das war cool das
möchte ich es bitte immer haben
so jetzt hier im stellen abwarten jetzt
hero das war sehr sehr lucky so freunde
4 ist gepackt und jetzt jetzt ich will
hier muss ich irgendwie hoch
da ist wieder so ein blöder zeiger so
kommen jetzt kommt jetzt zur zeit und
ich muss es doch irgendwie schaffen man
jetzt habe ich wieder dieses coole ding
hier dass die alle wissen worauf ich
mich mit mir ich mache euch kaputt genau
so heißt das übrigens auch ob slomo
jetzt hier den scheiß hier den scheiß
hier oben hoch weg tetris
sag jetzt mal wieder laden hier
funktionieren das kann jetzt eigentlich
nicht so schwer sein wenn man sich mal
überlegt ich will einfach so ein fucking
ball und muss hier einfach irgendwie nur
hochkommen mehr muss ich eigentlich gar
nicht machen das ist ja eigentlich mal
nicht schlimm
jetzt packt das ding jetzt hier weg
sollen endlich hier eben hoch so jetzt
du lässt mich jetzt mal eben hier oben
möchte ich bitte einmal kurz durch so
einen kleinen moment so hier hoch hier
und beim bruder und jetzt nehme ich mir
natürlich die spirale
das ist jetzt natürlich wieder eine
okay okay der allerletzte ran
der allerletzte ran freunde ich bin ja
jemand der sagt eigentlich die hält das
ein was er sagt beziehungsweise manchmal
aber bei solchen spielen da ich mir
einfach immer nur so der nächste dran er
muss doch mal irgendwie jetzt erfolg
bringt seine freunde wir sind schon bei
3 jetzt habe ich hier auch noch die
sprungfeder ihnen hier mache ich eben
noch kaputt wir sind bei vier freunde
wir müssen sechs schaffen
und wenn das wirklich der letzte run ist
dann mich erinnert übrigens das ganze so
ein bisschen